Prince Harry
Prince Harry and his new tell-all memoir
book by the man who just wants to be
left alone the man who only wants
privacy and that's why he's writing
books and doing Netflix movies and going
on TV to any channel that will have him
Prince Harry
is just admitted
that he has done a lot of drugs
a lot shocking I know he's done a lot of
drugs and the worst part of that is
he says that those drugs have helped him
see the truth
and Prince Harry's life and all the poor
decisions he's making
it's all starting to make sense to me
Harry says that while cocaine made him
feel different it did not make him
notably happier but mushrooms did when
he took magic mushrooms in California
while drinking a lot of tequila that had
a profound impact and here's this here's
this amazing experience he had he says
he saw a bathroom trash can that looked
like it was staring back at him and
growing ahead and then the toilet turned
into a head and began talking to him and
he says this was the experience of a
lifetime man you know because like when
you really want to understand the truth
you know it's it's not that you should
pray to God for clarity and meditate on
the on the Eternal things and it's not
that you should read a lot of books Say
by wise writers no it's that you should
eat poisonous mushrooms and stare into
the toilet that's going to teach you the
truth man because it's going to like
grow ahead or whatever and then
apparently two years after this
experience what happened Harry married
Meghan Markle okay starting to starting
to make sense now
Harry said he was able to see another
world
and and it it left him with the
impression that this other world is just
as real and twice as beautiful as the
one that we're all living in which is
not all there isn't and Harry said when
he saw this world
only the truth existed
so first of all Prince Harry admitting
to doing all these drugs especially in
the United States could screw up his
visa application this actually could be
a good excuse for the United States to
boot him out because it means he almost
certainly lied on his immigration papers
and if he did not lie and he told the
truth and he was using these illicit
drugs that also would be a reason to
boot him out
but beyond that
hopeful thought for a second
just to the point that Harry is making
I've seen it happen before I have
friends who have done this who have
taken mushrooms or acid more often acid
or one of these even more intense kind
of psychedelic drugs shrooms too though
and they'll say you know man I just saw
and it gave me peace because I saw all
the other beings and they showed me and
I'm not joking I've had friends tell me
and I realized man there's no devil
there's no hell there's no sin
is it what
yeah man I just realized like we're all
one you know we're all one and I saw
these little kind of beings popping out
and I said you saw like you're saying
you saw incorporeal
Spiritual Beings that told you there's
no sense of sin and you don't need to
fear hell
I think you were talking to a demon I'm
pretty sure no man I well then what was
it were you just imagining it no man it
was totally real okay so you're saying
it wasn't just some figment of your
imagination you were talking to a real
it not physical
this is a purely spiritual being that is
telling you don't worry about going to
hell and don't worry about committing
sins that's a demon that's what that's
what demons are that's how demons behave
man and the proof of the pudding is in
the tasting
the proof of the Yorkshire pudding is in
the tasting here for Prince Harry
because it does not seem that his life
has improved when he has done these
things even searching for deeper meaning
you are not going to find deeper meaning
by eating poisonous mushrooms
I remember my friends would ask me and
say Michael don't you want to open up
your mind man see experience the truth
and I thought well I try to do that like
for instance when I go sit outside at
night and read a book like when I read a
really wise deep profound book
that also changes the Pathways in my
brain
that also allows me to see things that I
previously couldn't see before but it
does so without poisoning the most
important organ in my body
and it does so
without opening me up to an experience
that you describe as being a perfect
description of talking to Demons you
know it just allows me to kind of sit
out
think and get smarter and growing wisdom
if only Harry had done that he would be
in a much better spot if only our
culture valued that sort of thing
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it
become a member and use code Knowles
kwels at checkout for two months free
on all of the annual plans we will see
you at the member block
[Music]
foreign